madame la présidente
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
sur le rapporteur général les serres
collègues
je m'adresse d'abord à tous nos
collègues qui ont voté par inadvertance
contre le pgl pouvoir d'achat mercredi
voici aujourd'hui avec ce plfr votre
session de rattrapage
revenons un instant sur des principales
mesures pour protéger nos concitoyens du
retour de l'inflation je n'en citerai
que quelques-unes comme la
revalorisation de 4% des pensions de
retraite des minima sociaux et des aides
aux plus fragiles la revalorisation de 3
5% du point d'indicé les trois fonctions
publiques la suppression de la
contribution à l'audiovisuel public ou
encore la prolongation et
l'élargissement de la prima kron je
tiens mes chers collègues à saluer
d'abord
nos discussions une autre travail commun
avec les sénateurs qui nous ont permis
d'aboutir à 2cm p conclusive je pense
bien sûr à la décomptabilisation de la
hache dans la loi pouvoir d'achat mais
aussi à tant d'autres dispositifs que
nous sommes appelés à voter aujourd'hui
en premier lieu je voudrais citer ceux
en faveur des travailleurs vous savez
tous l'attachement du groupe démocrate a
une meilleure rémunération du
travailleur nous saluons ainsi la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires jusqu'à 2000 jusqu'à
7500 euros la possibilité de monétiser
les rtt jusqu'en 2025 nous donnons le
temps d'évaluer cette mesure ou encore
l'ouverture de la prime exceptionnelle
de rentrée non seulement aux
bénéficiaires des minima sociaux mais
aussi à ceux qui travaillent et qui
touchent la prime d'activité nous sommes
aussi fiers d'avoir réussi à vous
convaincre chers collègues et en
particulier nos collègues du groupe
renaissance de l'utilité d'ouvrir la
prime transport à l'ensemble des
salariés et en doubler le plafond de la
part carburant et en permettant le cumul
avec le remboursement d'un abonnement de
transports en commun ce qui doit
encourager la multimodalité vrai chemin
à venir je ne peux citer ici les
nombreuses autres mesures mais je
m'arrête un instant sur les mesures de
compensation aux collectivités saluons
d'abord le travail mené en la matière à
l'assemblée à l'initiative notamment de
nos collègues christine pires bonne
charles de courson véronique louwagie et
du rapporteur général jean-rené
cazeneuve qui nous a permis d'atteindre
un consensus qui nous a semblé juste et
beau nos collègues sénateurs ont voulu
aller plus loin en augmentant les
critères départ le brut se recettes
réelles de fonctionnement de 10 à 22 %
triple en triplant quasiment le coût du
dispositif que nous avions adopté et au
vu de l'augmentation en 2022 en 2023 de
leurs recettes nous nous questionnons
sur l'opportunité d'une telle mesure
tâchons dans nos discussions de rester
raisonnables et cet avertissement vaut
aussi bien pour notre majorité et que
parce que charité bien ordonnée commence
par soi-même également à notre groupe
cette loi de finances rectificative est
une loi d'urgence et c'est comme ça que
nous l'avons abordée cela ne doit
cependant pas occulter les enjeux futurs
ni dévié de nos objectifs de bonne
gestion des deniers publics
permettez moi d'en dresser quelques
priorités pour les prochaines années
notre groupe réaffirme son appel à
rationaliser la dépense publique sur le
temps long en poursuivant les réformes
structurelles qui seul garantiront le
pouvoir d'achat des ménages nous devons
aussi réfléchir plus largement à des
réformes fiscale et structurelles pour
mieux accompagner l'innovation et la
prise de risque sans toutefois oublier
la notion de justice il est de notre
responsabilité
de continuer dans notre volonté de
transformer l'économie tout en tirant
les leçons de ce qui n'a pas fonctionné
au cours des dernières décennies
nous devrons enfin accélérer la
transition écologique et énergétique
rénover les logements qui sont les
premiers consommateurs des espaces et
d'énergie en encourageant les
investisseurs vertueux et en aidant les
particuliers à mieux s'équiper en
augmentant ma prime rennes-om et en
facilitant le changement de chaudière la
chaire mes chers collègues nous sommes
un parti de gouvernement et c'est avec
esprit avec cet esprit responsable avec
cet esprit constructif que nous voterons
pour ce texte je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]